Speaker 2: radical and very repugnant Republican
repugnant.
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE
appears to have kicked a gun safety activist
two times.
And it's on video.
This is these are the people who say we're
against violence, I guess.
I mean, I don't know.
It seems like they're against it only in certain
cases.
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE denies
she kicked an 18 year old political activist
in an incident caught on video in which it's
pretty damn clear that that's exactly what
she did.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE was walking behind
gun rights activist Marianna Pecora.
Marianna Pecora is holding a phone recording
and not once, but twice in this video, I see
Marjorie Taylor GREENE deliberately looking
down and appearing to kick Mariana Pecora.
This is an elected member of Congress.
Yes, elected by lunatics, but that is the
United States of America.
Lunatics are allowed to elect whoever they
want, and lunatics are allowed to run and
sometimes they elect each other.
Let's take a look at this video, see what
you make of it.
And again, if you're just listening today,
I'll describe it.
Speaker 3: Deciding how to run the world.
I want to go east.
Speaker 2: Okay.
So there's the first kick.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE kind of speeding up.
And you can tell that she just she steps on
or kicks her and then Mariano kind of moves
to her.
Right.
And then it happens again right here.
And then a second kick.
And of course, it's all under the guise of,
oh, you're walking right in front of me and
so closely and all of these different things.
Oh, it's.
It's all an accident.
Speaker 3: I'll be back here next block.
Speaker 2: You're blocking the congresswoman.
That's why she kicked you twice a year.
Speaker 3: When you can't block members of
Congress say, are you okay?
You literally cannot get to work.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
So there is Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
And remember, she is in favor of due process
and she's in favor of the rule of law.
She's for law and order.
She's against violence.
And yet you see that she very clearly kind
of speeds up in order to kick her on the back
of the leg and kicks her two or three times.
This woman is truly the lowest of the low.
It looks like assault to me.
I hope Mariana Pecora presses charges, and
initially there was a camera angle that made
it seem potentially accidental.
There really seems to be no question here
that it's intentional.
It's just a question of can you actually demonstrate
that or show it for sure.
But think about how far you know, it's we've
talked about their allegations are actually
confessions.
Oh, the Democrats are going to use voter fraud
and try to steal an election they don't win.
So what Republicans did right and we have
dozens of such examples when here it comes
to this issue of we're against violence, but
you should be able to talk about anything
you want.
Remember, they love saying that on Twitter.
You should be able to talk about whatever
you want.
And there should never you know, we don't
use physical accosting or violence or we don't
do that is everybody should be allowed to
talk and say whatever they want free from
violence.
Well, here is a public street where an activist
goes to Marjorie Taylor GREENE and asks a
question about the Second Amendment, which
is what they claim we should all be able to
do.
I mean, it's America, after all.
And Marjorie Taylor GREENE kicks this woman
at least twice, if not three times.
Their principles don't matter once they are
inconvenient.
And questions about the Second Amendment in
these formats are inconvenient to these Republicans.
And so this is the outcome.
It's truly despicable.
I hope charges are filed